oh celery juice
hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by beltbar and
we'll be reviewing another harper's bazaar
food diaries by american actress kate hudson but
first let me tell you about my sponsor buildbar so
if you are new here welcome uh but of
course my regular viewers know that i
very much love these bars because i think they
taste like a chocolate bar and you know protein
bars are just such an easy convenient source of
protein for those really super crazy days and
we are living in a pandemic so i know we
all got a lot of those i have tried a lot of
protein bars in my day and i find most of
them taste like chalk but these ones oh no
they actually taste like a chocolate bar and
i think kate would also approve just saying
all right let's see what flavor we gonna get
into today it's so hard to chew sometimes
what am i in the mood for something super
chocolatey something more fruity i don't know
coconut almond yeah let's let's throw
all of my favorite flavors together
this one right here 18 grams of protein i think
i've tried this one before i can't remember
took a big bite it's gonna take a while
don't judge me a few moments later tastes
like a vacation and i'm here for it these are
a lower sugar bar for those who are looking
for that but of course if i was having this as my
post-workout snack or part of my post-workout meal
i'd probably pair it with a source of carbs like
some fruit oatmeal some toast etc but if you want
to give these bars a try check out the link in
the description and use my promo code for 15
off of your order also super quick before
we dive in you can pause the screen
or check out the description to look at my
disclaimer including a trigger warning to
those with current or previous experiences with
disordered eating i will be evaluating meals based
on their nutritional mira alone which as we know
says very little about their overall value so if
that is not supporting your food journey by all
means sit this one out and of course don't forget
to subscribe to this channel and ring that little
bell so that you never miss out on an episode
all right folks let's get eating am i gonna get
up 15 minutes from now or am i just gonna go back
to sleep and then i drink water the fact that
there isn't lemon in this water is borderline
triggering for me like could this
day of eating possibly be [ __ ] free
i do not eat first thing in the morning the first
thing i do in the morning is i have celery juice
never mind and uh if anybody does celery juice
on an empty stomach they know why because it's
a joyous morning activity so the joyous activity
that kate is referring to is pooping of course it
is joyous gotta love a good poop celery is rich
in a fodmap called mannitol which actually pulls
water into the bowels which can cause diarrhea
cramping and the urgency to go now most people can
tolerate a little celery in their salad but just
two stalks of celery are considered high fodmap
by the monash institute so if you drink a whole
glass of celery juice comprised of an entire bunch
of celery well yeah for some folks you're going to
want to stay close to home it's coming out of me
like lava two soft boiled eggs with some sourdough
and butter and avocado with olive oil and sea salt
classic and a great sounding balanced breakfast so
we got protein in the eggs fiber in the sourdough
and healthy fats in the avocado and the olive
oil i guess there's a reason why this is like
the pandemic breakfast of wellness influencers
everywhere it's just pretty great oatmeal with
like almond butter and banana and maybe some
blueberries some maple syrup cinnamon chia seeds
maybe some walnuts in there so this also sounds
really good if you're craving the kind of sweet
breakfast option so we've got fiber
rich carbs and the oats and fruit
healthy fats and protein in the chia almond butter
walnuts all the good things love it delish so
yeah we've got some options if we're feeling the
sweet or if we're feeling the savory walnuts are
i feel like they're underrated i feel
like more people use almonds or cashews
but a walnut a walnut in your oatmeal is
really i'm personally not a walnut fan
i think they're a little bitter and dry just
saying but they are probably one of the most
nutritious nuts you can eat so compared with the
almonds and cashews that she cited and actually
all other nuts too walnuts have more heart-healthy
omega-3s which is really a unique selling feature
in the nut world so a great addition to a bowl of
oats on the go i'm going to just get a smoothie
lunch ish a smoothie for me would be like
a protein based drink i like the chocolatey
type flavors like banana and almond butter and
chocolate simple but i would say relatively
light lunch option but if there was ever
a three ingredient combo that delivered
in the protein shake category it would be
chocolate protein powder banana and almond
butter or peanut butter i like peanut butter but
anyways we've got protein in the protein powder
fiber in the fruit and the almond butter and
those healthy fats in the almonds as well
solid option but again like i said not a very
substantial lunch if she was feeling like in
the sweet brunchy mood i would personally want
to maybe throw in some veg to that smoothie
and also start with a source of carbohydrates
like some toast or some yogurt and fruit chop
salad that's kind of a go-to for me i do extra
salami no cheese cucumbers no tomatoes basil and
extra dressings so not really a chopped
salad what is this i don't know more
like a charcuterie board with like some
sauce on there but sounds a delicious
charcuterie board with sauce at that now you guys
all know that i'm all about adding in nutritious
ingredients to build a more nutrient-dense meal
so if she want to keep that salami and dressing
even if this did add and increase the saturated
fat and sodium in the meal i would suggest just
throwing in some more nutritious ingredients
to bulk this up so some great nutrients dense
chopped salad friendly options that she could kind
of throw in there to make up for the items that
she omitted would be things like chickpeas eggs
olives bell peppers avocado corn radishes etc and
also pairing it with maybe some pita or throwing
in some quinoa or faro or another grain just to
bulk up the carbs to make it a little bit more
satiating i always try to find at least a half
hour to work out i think it's important to try to
take time to move your body most days of the week
and it doesn't need to be like a strenuous boot
camp but even a walk around the neighborhood or
some youtube yoga for example would be a really
great addition to your day and there are days when
even something like this is not gonna happen
and that is totally okay i think it's equally
important to cut yourself some slack not let it
trigger like restrictive compensatory behaviors
and just carry on with your week as usual just
remember that missing a workout here or there
is going to have zero impact on your health
status or weight it's all about the overall
behavioral patterns is there an animal in my bush
that's what she said i don't know what you're
talking about i had to i try not to be a big
snacker but i love a snack why is the word snack
so triggering to so many health enthusiasts
like why is it automatically a bad word
i think that diet culture has hijacked the
concept of snacking to become synonymous
with like a treat or ultra processed food but
really a snack to me is just like a mini meal
it's just a bridge meal to get you to
that more substantial sit down experience
so ideally your snack includes you know the
hunger crushing combo of fiber protein and
fat it can actually look identical to a meal
but just smaller and maybe a little bit simpler
so there should of course be room for fun
foods too in your diet but this to me is
different than a snack and this language becomes
a lot more important when you're raising kids
for whom snacks are really key but let's see what
her snacks of choice are you cannot stay away
from chips and salsa and simple mills makes an
amazing cheddar almond flour it's like a cheez-it
but healthy okay so we need to vote in the chip
dip trifecta what would you choose salsa guac
or sour cream guac is number one for me and
also it would make the snack more satiating of
course because of the fiber and healthy fats
in the avocado but salsa is a close second
i don't like sour cream i don't know don't come
at me it just doesn't have enough flavor for me
i don't know i i i think sour cream just needs
like some salt or something so i guess if the
chips are salty enough it balances itself up
i'm here for it but yeah let me know below
anyways as for the simple mills cheddar crackers
these crackers are made out of almond flour and
i actually really like them too but if you want to
see how they stack up against a typical cheez-it
let's take a look now the healthier almond flour
version actually has slightly more calories the
same amount of protein and fiber and almost the
same amount of sodium yes it's gluten-free where
the classic cheez-its are not but if you really
want your cheez-its and you're eating almond flour
cheese crackers reluctantly because you think it's
a much healthier choice i'm just here to tell you
that maybe it's not super sound logic so choose
the cracker that you love and if you want
you can make it even more nutritious by pairing it
with a more substantial source of protein fiber or
healthy fats like nuts seeds or actual cheese just
saying i try to get everybody to do five between 5
30 and 6. if that doesn't happen for me i i like
to eat before seven unless i'm going out you know
which nobody i don't do that anymore welcome to
the geriatric dinner club folks but also this kind
of just like comes with the parenthood territory
i think anyways i'm definitely interested to
hear about some of her family meals one of my
favorite meals nutmeg chicken it's shallots
it's lemon fresh herbs brown the chicken in the
oven and you make this like nutmeg gravy and you
and rice that sounds incredible love a good roast
chicken and i'm really intrigued by this nutmeg
gravy situation definitely an unusual pairing but
i am here for it and honestly chicken is always a
really great easy lean protein dinner main to
pair with maybe some rose veggies or like she
does some rice so any kind of starch potatoes
whole grains rice love it this sounds like a
really great family meal sweet corn pasta that
my kids love it's pancetta peas corn white wine
butter and olive oil and cream oh that right there
totally my style perfect summer pasta dish and
while i have no qualms about just enjoying a carb
and cream combo like this straight up if you want
to balance this out a bit you could throw in some
canned chickpeas for some protein or some leftover
chicken and toss in tons of fresh summer squash
and zucchini but yeah sounds really really good
just as it is too i want to mess with perfection
we had the greatest matzo ball soup that grandma
used to make and then mom made this chicken
and dumplings that was my grandma's recipe
that was like it's out of this world and
then mom also makes a biscuit and gravy
as a jewish mama i would describe those three
things as like jewish meets southern comfort food
warm kind of salty hearty and let's be
real kind of constipated but honestly
i am here for it a good biscuit
is worth being a little backed up
it's sparkling water all day long okay but let's
talk about sparkling water for a second so a lot
of people ask me what those natural flavors in
sparkling water are and if they're like toxic or
what now this was an especially hot topic after
there was a class action lawsuit against lacroix
or lacroix or whatever around whether or not said
natural flavors were in fact natural so to start
natural is kind of an ambiguous and
controversial term in the food industry
basically anything can be labeled as natural
as long as it doesn't contain any added color
artificial flavors or synthetic substances but
the fda specifically defines natural flavors
as the essential oil olio resin essence or
extractive protein hydrolysate distillate
or any product of roasting heating or enzymolysis
which contains the flavoring constituents derived
from spice fruit or fruit juice vegetable or
vegetable juice edible yeast herb bark bud
root leaf or similar plant material meat seafood
poultry eggs dairy products or fermentation of
products thereof whose significant function
in food is flavoring rather than nutritional
that one was a doozy and reading that is enough
for most people to just say what the does that
mean and either just conclude that it's healthy
or it's toxic depending which way you sway in the
absence of useful evidence-based information
so here's what we know these natural flavors
are classified under the fda's category
of generally recognized as safe or grass
and if you look deeper at most of the popular
sparkling water companies like lacroix
and bubbly most specifically do say that their
flavor is coming from extracts or essences from
fruits and vegetables but as a general rule of
thumb on this manufacturers don't actually have to
reveal their sources so we don't really know where
these natural flavors come from not to mention the
fda's definition of natural flavors suggests that
while these substances do have to have natural
origins they can be chemically altered to create a
desirable flavor so how you interpret this really
is up to you but we do have no evidence that these
flavors are doing any harm so until that changes
i'm gonna keep drinking my beloved bubbly and
kate you can too i could do this forever i want
to talk about food all day long anything from
the foie gras to the chicken to the shoestring
potatoes how much time do we have because i
could keep going oh oh my god i am having major
foodie wanderlust fomo right now oh i just
want to travel and eat all the things guys
let's beat this cobit thing all right back to
the food i really try not to late night snack
but i do again you know a late night snack doesn't
have to be bad it's not that food consumed after 8
pm automatically turns to fat but i will say that
research on our circadian alignment does suggest
that insulin sensitivity is at its peak during
daytime hours so if we can align our food intake
with these hours it can have some benefit for our
metabolism and glucose response having said that
for most people this would be splitting hairs and
not likely to cause any major shifts on the scale
so whether you eat 500 calories in ice cream
above your caloric needs at 8 a.m or 8 p.m it's
going to have approximately the same net of a 500
calorie surplus everyone can't seem to get through
a night without having like a big snack at 2 am
so yeah i'm hoping that kind of shifts and works
itself out when i stop pumping in the night
but let's see what she's having for her snack
yeah and my late night snack is always going
to be in the ice cream department same and
you know just know that reaching for foods that
are higher in sugar salt and fat in the evening
is actually incredibly common we don't know for
sure why this is but part of it is likely that
we've been socialized to curl up on the couch with
like a bag of chips and a pint of ben and jerry's
rather than a bowl of celery and carrots i mean an
entire genre of young adult media has been built
on this classic rom-com trope but it
also may have to do with the fact that
at the end of the night and at the end of the day
we are tired you know our inhibitions are down
and for those with tumultuous relationships with
food we're kind of just too exhausted to restrict
anymore and so out comes the ice cream and down
the hatch she goes they do great oat milk ice
creams now so i try to stay non-dairy because it's
a little bit better for me so i'm not sure if kate
hudson is completely dairy-free for a specific
reason and that's why she's suggesting that it's
better for her to go with the oat milk based
yogurt versus the regular but generally speaking
if you're going to eat ice cream i say choose
the one that is most enjoyable to you if we're
to compare the labels of my favorite ice cream
flavor ben and jerry's netflix and chilled which
is oh my gosh it is so good um the dairy-free
version has 10 calories and 2 grams of fat less
but it actually has more sugar and less protein
per serving as well so is it really healthier not
necessarily for everyone depending on your health
goals but if you don't digest dairy very well and
you can still derive that same amount of pleasure
from the dairy free version then of course it is
the better option for you mint chip i love because
it's refreshing but i really like like a dolce de
leche type of and with chocolate chips i think
kate and i are kind of kindred spirits because
i think we like the same ice cream flavors like
dolce de leche is life and mint chocolate chip was
always my favorite as a kid and i still do enjoy
me a good mint chip but leave me a comment below
on your favorite flavor because i don't know i
could read about and talk about ice cream all day
long tell me what's your flavor but
don't tell me you like vanilla because
just know why would you choose vanilla when you
can have vanilla with something else in it i just
don't understand i'm not a big fan of like rice
puddings anything that gets too like i don't know
creamy i know the word she's looking for and
it's gloopy right i mean i love a good rice
pudding i was raised on rice pudding but there
is definitely some interesting textural contrast
going on so i understand that rice pudding is a
little controversial but you know what's even more
controversial raisins in your rice pudding are you
team raisin or team no raisin because i'm a purist
like nothing else other than rice and cream and
sugar and whatever the hell else maybe some egg
yolks or something nothing else cinnamon you can
put cinnamon and rice pudding but nothing else
no raisins no chocolate chips no other weird
ingredients thank you very much okay well i'm
getting a little bit off topic but what can we say
about kate's diet and relationship with food well
i think we're seeing a lot of the classic wellness
culture staples so celery juice protein oatmeal
protein shake and the avocado toast what i like
is that these are juxtaposed against some comfort
soul food options like the chicken and biscuits
and the sweet corn and bacon pasta chips and salsa
and a good roast chicken with a rich gravy i
think it's clear to me that kate loves food
as evidenced by her like waxing poetic about all
of her favorite food cities and foodie travels but
she's also interested in taking care of her body
through daily movement and nutrient dense food
is she influenced by diet culture likely i
mean the woman owns an athleisure line so
this is kind of part of her brand but unlike
other wellness influencers like guena paltrow
i get the sense that she's probably a lot
more chill at least as far as family meals go
i don't think she's like putting her kids on
detoxes or super restrictive diets and it does
sound like she's prioritizing family meals which
i think is so important as for suggestions it's
hard to really get a sense of exactly how kate's
meals come together from a format like this but if
i had any suggestion it would maybe be to bulk
up that midday meal by adding in some carbs so
you know some toast to the smoothie or some grains
to the salad this might help make the meal a lot
more satiating so that she wouldn't feel the need
to overdo it on chips and dip in the afternoon
i would also just remind her and also all of
you that there's nothing wrong with snacking
but we can also make our snack more satiating by
focusing on the hunger crushing combo of fiber
protein and fat so rather than getting
rid of the chips if she loves the chips
maybe pairing them with a source of fat like
guacamole to just balance things out and make
it more satiating and on that note that is all
that i have for you guys today thank you again to
builtbar for sponsoring this video if you liked
it be sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on who you'd like to see me review
next subscribe to the channel and i will see you
next time on abby's kitchen bye and for more great
videos like this check out the link right here
you